let's start with something a little
different today I I kind of like this
quite a bit Byron Donald's and Jamal
Bowman are two members of Congress Byron
Donalds is a republican from Florida
Jamal Bowman is a Democrat representing
New York they had a debate of sorts on
the steps of the capital in Washington
D.C and it is cartoonish in a way
there's not like deep policy substance
here but I would much prefer this debate
to what we've seen recently in terms of
our elected officials engaging in so
let's take a look at this this happening
on the steps of the capital in DC you
will see Byron Donald's on on the left
of the screen and then Jamal Bowman will
pop up and be on the right of the screen
what I will say first for the
gentleman from New York man listen
it's cool I have two people in my state
that could be president I don't know
about New York that's all I'm gonna say
though that's all I'm saying
[Music]
they're like uh it's really not that but
people are trying to raise a fuss I've
had the conversations that's not true
why can't uh
into our release who have done their
time why can't they be re-enfranchised
and be allowed to vote they are in our
state
who's the second guy second person come
on now you already know that Trump and
Ron I'm Trump
so Trump claims Florida now he
knows
three years now
I said that's what he said that's what
he said to Kathy oh he told Kathy
Holcomb like so I got to go both those
dudes gonna get crushed
oh
the man of 1600 correction please if she
wanted to jump in she would kill both of
them secondly Biden will kill both of
them buying them past three
this is arguably the best part here
coming up
fighting past three bipartisan pieces of
legislation after an Insurrection during
a global pandemic open back up to some
movies
in what world come on in what world
bizarre land ships infrastructure bills
safer communities uh historic investors
to climate 35 insulin High inflation
over on Southern border depending on
everybody's streets we could do the same
thing I could do the same thing
all right so so listen what what did we
learn right
only one person there was actually armed
with facts okay that that's the reality
it was Jamal Bowman but they were at
least relatively more substantive
discussions than Jewish space lasers
woke masks uh trans whatever the case
may be now this was not a debate in the
sense that you can't really debate with
someone who's simply refusing to
acknowledge basic facts you can't and
Donald's is of course complicit in the
hate and the anger that is driving
Republican voters to do what they do
that's all very sad right so I'm not
saying oh two good faith participants
and whatever fine but notice that
whenever policy accomplishments are
brought up there by Jamal Bowman
Byron Donald's can say nothing but no
stop stop no when Bowman cites actual
Biden accomplishments and this is what
the right has they have in their worst
cases right like Marjorie Taylor green
they have that completely unhinged
rhetoric in the best cases where it's
sort of congenial and generally speaking
respectful as this was they still have
nothing more on policy and that's
extraordinarily telling and then of
course the fact that Byron Donalds
thinks we have we have such Rich we have
a richness of candidates in Florida
we've got Trump
and we've got to stand this now I don't
know that I share Bowman's confidence
that Biden would wipe the floor with
DeSantis that remains to be seen But if
more of the conversations among our
elected officials were like this I mean
I'd rather them be more like the Lincoln
Douglas debates okay but that ship seems
to have sailed a couple hundred years
ago if they were more like this than
what we normally get I actually would
prefer it let me know what you think one
of our sponsors today is Leisure of NYC
offering Ultra comfortable fair trade
men's clothing at fair prices guys know
it can be very tough to find good boxers
and t-shirts the search is over because
all boxer briefs by Leisure of NYC are
made with amazingly soft moisture
wicking viscose from bamboo super
lightweight like air but it doesn't
Bunch up and it's also great for the
planet Leisure of NYC also makes really
great supima cotton crew neck t-shirts
less than one percent of men's Basics
today are made with supima cotton it is
the best out there it feels like Silk
quite frankly you can walk around in a
scratchy t-shirt all day or you can
enjoy the cloud soft feel of supima
cotton and actually love the shirt
you're wearing these are my go-to
t-shirts and boxers nothing else even
comes close to providing this level of
comfort and all of their products are
fair trade and made sustainably go pick
up the most comfortable t-shirts and
boxers you will ever own but hurry
because they often sell out especially
the boxers go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you will get 15 off with the
code Pacman at checkout and the link is
down below